Hydra Red Skull super soldier ship
sounds like some other funny papers
you have no idea where to fight against
robots from another planet you want to
wipe us out take the earth
we succeed there will not be any shield
in the future something even worse could
rise up we can't disrupt the timeline
just do it deacon he's just a kid
take a shot
the guns are now
but close velikiy medicine somewhere
else hey yo no no I warned you once
about bleeding on the floor she needs
help
doctor friends gonna meet us here we're
worse Freddy wait they're not back yet
but who the hell are you the new gang
they're after Freddie applesauce he's a
nobody
he's a target give me a reason they're
not after his dad's money when old man
Malick jumped out that window his texts
were paid what'd you just call this full
name what is it Alfred Malik why Wolford
Malik as in father of Gideon Malick
future head of Hydra in America the
chronic comes to kill Malik that Hydra
stamped out before it ever takes hold
and shields never formed so you're
saying to save shield
we have to save Hydra great
oh dear agent May it is I Enoch
sentient Crona calm trusted friend I am
here to help how could you lose her you
had one job Enoch one job
agents of shield the final mission
continues next Wednesday on ABC welcome
back everyone it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Avengers endgame MCU agents of
shield season 7 crossover connections
Easter eggs video that's right there's
gonna be a bunch of big crossover stuff
happening this season on agents of
shield so we'll break it down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we'll do
an Amazon giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and let me know
if they're doing a bunch of time travel
which big MCU moments you want them to
visit during the season and if you
didn't know this is the final season of
agents of shield but the producers said
that there would be a big MCU crossover
a really big crossover and I think that
has something to do with the rumors
about the agents of sword TV show on
Nick Fury's space station for Disney
Plus that's rumored to be the successor
showed to agents of shield with quakes
characters so I'll talk about that in
the video too but what's happening on
agents of shield right now is that they
brought Coulson back he's died a couple
times on the show but he died last
season again this version of Coulson is
now full-blown life model decoy bringing
the joke from The Avengers movie with
Iron Man trying to duck Coulson full
circle now Coulson is the life model
decoy you have reached the life model
decoy of Tony Stark please leave a
message
this is urgent then leave it urgently
security breach the joke in early
seasons of the show - is that people
thought that when he first came back
because they killed him during the
Avengers movie and he showed up in
agents of shield season one people were
like is he a life model decoy how is he
still alive
so was sort of a play on that big joke
but they've uploaded all of the original
Coulson's memories into his brain so the
whole idea is that the technology that
he's built from is the same as these
chronic comms if you don't know who the
chronic comms are they're basically like
robot Watchers that are sentient and
normally good characters but this is a
rogue faction so just imagine the
villains this season as being what if
the Watchers but evil what if they
decided to use their extreme cosmic
power to try and control history instead
of just observe it patton oswalt here is
playing the grandfather of one of the
characters he played earlier on the show
the Kane eggs and right now as you can
see from the Empire State Building which
is currently under construction they're
in the early 1930s so a long time before
the events of Captain America First
Avenger and they obviously reference a
bunch of MCU events during that trailer
as they explained during the episode the
chronic comms are targeting Hydra
because the person that they're trying
to kill in the episode was an early
member of Hydra and the father of the
person that would eventually help create
shield so that's what Coulson's talking
about when he says we have to save Hydra
and because it's a time-travel show
they'll be jumping through time as they
go and trying to stop the chronic comms
who are time travelers from altering key
events in MCU history so you kind of get
the theme of season 7 they're doing the
Avengers end game thing where they jump
through time and visit big MCU moments
they show footage from Captain America
Winter Soldier except they add the
Triskelion being blown up they
referenced the Super Soldier program and
Captain America that was all government
early shield stuff before shield was
actually called shield it was called the
SSR and that's why Peggy Carter Howard
Stark and Colonel Phillips from the
Captain America movie were instrumental
in creating shield when Coulson talks
about not disrupting the timeline
causing more problems they show a scene
of the Helicarrier referencing the
Avengers movie and speaking of time
travel they do follow most of the same
rules as Avengers end game time-travel
rules we'll call that MCU time trial
the way the hook explains it is that you
can't change your past but you can
create alternate timelines that branch
out from moments in history so even
though they're trying to protect the
future of shield and the MCU the
Avengers during this season they're also
trying to prevent another multiverse
catastrophe with hundreds and thousands
of more branching timelines this also
connects with what's going on in the
Loki TV series for Disney Plus there are
actual time cops in the MCU that try to
police this kind of thing we're gonna
meet them on the Loki series like you
see Loki is sitting in their prison in
the trailer here saying he's gonna burn
this place to the ground
they're called the time variant
authority and they hail from the Thor
and the Fantastic Four comics the Loki
series is gonna be him trying to mess
with the timeline using the tesseract
it's the Loki from Avengers end game
that escaped to create an alternate
timeline with the Infinity stone so when
the ancient one is telling Hulk about
the nature of those alternate timelines
that they could possibly create to the
detriment of this one timeline the time
variant authority are the ones that come
in and try to clean up messes like that
if they find someone like Loki with the
tesseract trying to mess with the
timeline or other big time-travel
villains like King the conker who's also
rumored to show up during the Loki
series they move to capture and imprison
them you could also think of them as
like Time Lords so I'm sure there's
gonna be lots of Doctor Who references
during that series and even though the
virus kind of delayed everything this
year they still will premiere the Loki
series next year at some point it just
might be delayed by a couple weeks if
you're really excited about that - there
are also rumors now based on what Tom
Hiddleston is saying that they're
already planning for a Loki season - so
that would be pretty cool if they do
multiple seasons - some of these Disney
Plus series the reason why you're not
seeing the time variant authority get
involved in this show right now it's
just because they only just created the
Loki series so they're not even done
filming it so the whole concept of the
time variant authority the MCU isn't
something that they planned on a long
time ago so they just weren't able to
incorporate a lot that into this series
but like I said the producers are
teasing a big Marvel MCU crossover later
this season a really big one there are
13 episodes total so if they're jumping
around history of the MCU just like they
did during Avengers endgame
odds are that at least through the
regular episodes they'll reference other
big major Avengers MCU moments through
history that early prediction at the end
of it all thought T's agents of sword on
Nick Fury
space station because sword is sort of
the successor to shield in the comics
it's now where they're kind of moving
the MCU moving it into outer space
because that's where Nick Fury is
operating out of now we're gonna do a
lot more cosmic MCU movies so obviously
a lot more big Avengers level threats
will be coming from outer space and even
though they haven't officially announced
it there are rumors that they're
developing an agents of sword Disney
Plus series that some of these
characters would cross over onto maybe
this LMD version of Coulson mostly has
just been quakes character that they've
rumored with star in it I don't know
what their plans are for sword during
the Falcon and Winter Soldier series but
we do know that sword is a big part of
the Wanda vision series that's going to
be airing in December so we just sort of
them transitioning to the next phase
obviously Marvel phase four of the MCU
and where all this shield stuff used to
happen on earth now it's going to be
happening around outer space with more
cosmic stuff going on you just have to
picture an agents of shield post-credit
scene moment where they sort of linked
up with this spider-man far from home
Nick Fury post-credit scene moment with
him on the space station in terms of
what was going on with these characters
during avengers endgame when all the
snaps were happening Avengers infinity
war for the past couple of seasons
season six in now season seven they've
mostly been out of sync with the normal
flow of time so that's sort of the way
they explained around not being able to
do spoilers for Avengers infinity war
the snap or Avengers endgame the
producers haven't revealed every single
big MCU moment in history they're going
to visit every big Avengers moment but
if there are any really huge Avengers or
MCU Easter eggs or episodes that they do
of course I'll do Easter egg videos for
those but if you have any other big
questions about what's happening after
agents of shield ends this season or
what they're planning on doing next with
the characters if they'll show up in
other TV series that they're making for
Disney Plus just leave them in the
comments below for the most part a lot
of the major actors do say that they
want to come back like I'm sure Coulson
will find a way to come back at some
point he came back for the Captain
Marvel movie set in the past so if he's
gonna do that of course he'll price show
up in other big projects coming up but
while you wait for everything everyone
click here for my brand new Spider Man
Marvel what if trailer video breakdown
in Easter eggs and click here for my
breakdown of the one division Falcon in
Winter Soldier trailer and the Loki
trailer thank you so much for watching
everyone stays safe I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]